用女读者的眼睛，细读，文学，艺术，当代生活，我们在细读中介入世界，在闲谈中想象生活的其他可能。
欢迎收听姐姐好读。
如果小时候没有被好好地爱过，你真的会有这个能力来建立新的关系，建立良好的爱吗？
人天然有亲人，但是人不是天然有家人，家是需要构建的。
我觉得爱就是抓住和放手是同一个东西，拥有和放弃是同一个东西。
当你做到一切你能做到的，但与此同时给它自由，让它选择。
这太难了。
听众朋友们大家好，欢迎收听今天的姐姐好读。
今天我们要聊一个关于养育和童年的故事。
我是刚吃完烤肉的姐姐希希。
大家好，我是刚看完电影的姐姐老元。
大家好，我是刚从海边回来的小娇。
我们都度过了丰富的一天，现在晚上九点开始录制这期节目。
今天我们要聊的是一位一些短片小说著称的女作家，克拉尔吉根，是爱尔兰作家，1968年出生。
她成长于爱尔兰东南部，维克斯福德边境的农场家庭。
她是一个短片小说作家，写得很少也很慢。
有人统计过，在她1999年出版手作《南极以来》，她总共出版的五部作品加起来只有七百页，大约十四万字。
很多作家的一部小说就比这个要长了。
今天我们要聊的是吉根出版于2010年的短片小说《收留，Foster》。
我记得有一个译本也翻译成《继扬》。
可能有些听众不太了解这位作家，但是好在这个故事并不复杂。
用现在互联网流行的话来说，这是一个关于如何养育高敏感小孩的故事。
那故事大致是这样的。在1981年的夏天，阿尔兰乡间，一个九岁的小女孩，
被父亲送到亲戚家金塞拉夫妇那里赞助几个月。
在那里，她第一次被温柔耐心的对待，也第一次感觉到自己是被重视的。
但当她和这个家庭慢慢建立起感情，她又不得不回到原先的家庭。
小说就是用这个小女孩的第一视角展开了这一场夏日寄养的观察和体会。
那先来问问两位姐姐，你们在童年的时候有没有被短暂寄养在亲戚家的经历？
亲戚啊朋友啊，因为这个小说写的就是一个夏天几个月的时间，
她被寄养在一个亲戚家。
我有我有，而且我有好多。
对，因为我父母要去学习，我妈好像是去读研究生还是什么的，
然后我爸又要背考，所以就把我寄养在朋友家，寄养在二姨家，
而且我妈妈她是因为以前打乒乓球，
所以她是很早就去了广州，然后被寄养在广州的亲戚家，
所以她就发誓，她说她一定不要让她的小孩寄人离下，
但是尽管如此，我还是就是有过很多短暂的这种寄养的经历吧。
小焦有吗？我小的时候真的是一个非常可怕的高明感小孩，
就是有非常强烈的分离焦虑，
所以我当时上幼儿园的时候，我就去了两天，
因为那个幼儿园的那个后院正好对着我奶奶家的阳台，
我就不跟小朋友玩，我也不睡觉，我就站在那个后院里看着我奶奶家的阳台，
然后两天之后我奶奶受不了，就把我接回了家。
这感觉也是一个短片小说的画面。
对，所以我就连去幼儿园我都不行，
寄养对我来说会要了我的命，就是家里人无法想象，
所以我确实是没有这个经历的，太高明感了小的时候。
待会我们可以看看这个小说是怎么处理高明感小孩这个话题的。
我真的有寄养的经历，而且跟这个小说的民主角差不多一样大，
我一年级和二年级都是住在别人家的，
因为我去另外一个城区上小学，
所以当时就住在我爸妈的朋友家，
然后他们有一个女儿就跟我一样大，上同一个学校，
所以相当于我们就是白天一起上学，晚上在一张床上睡觉，
所以我今天读这个小说还挺有感触的，
因为我们自己现在可能有点想不起来八九岁的心情，
但是你看到这个作家的描述就会想起来，
其实我们当时能够观察到的，能够感受到的真的比我们想象的要多得多，
然后当时我特别特别感激我寄养的家庭的那个阿姨，
因为她就是严格遵循，平等，绝对的平等，
我就记得我们吃的，穿的，用的都一样，
即使是在这样的情况下，
你有时候还是会在有一些瞬间觉得，
哇，我是一个外人，
所以我觉得这个小说真的是很精准的捕捉到了，
小孩的视角。
那如果用一个词来形容这个小说带给你的阅读感受呢？
因为这小说真的很短，很快就看完了。
我觉得这个小说特别丰富，就是它虽然很短，
但是它特别丰富，然后我要说一个非常夸张的词，
但是确实是我的心里话，
太好奇了。
我就会觉得特别像桃花圆剂，看起来平平无奇，
但是你进去之后取尽通忧，
哇，里面就是非常丰富，
真的是非常喜欢这篇小说，
因为这个小说很短，
所以我也觉得听众朋友们，
就是如果你听完了我们这一期对这个小说感兴趣的话，
一定要去看，
你都不知道如果你不看你错过了什么。
哎，你说桃花圆剂取尽通忧，
所以是有一个瞬间，
你觉得在这个故事里面世界打开了吗？
当然我这个话又复夸了，
不知道这个听众朋友们有没有去过那个荣动，
就是你就一步一净，
每一个地方它都不一样，
这个小说它就有这样的魔力，
反正我是被深深的吸引了。
对，这期节目，
这位作家也是老元选送推荐的。
我想到的词跟你稍微有点不同，
我觉得是齿轮班精妙，
就是这个小说其实很短小，精汉，
而且它写的是一个非常日常的，
又是小女孩的视角，
但是给我的感觉就是，
我越往下读，
越觉得之前的每一句话都不是浪费的，
它用一种非常精炼准确的方式组织在一起，
所以也让我觉得很佩服这个作家。
真的，我们的感受并不完全一样的，
我是觉得它是很湿性的一种感觉，
因为我们说精确，
像齿轮一般，
就是它是有一个很好的逻辑之类的，
但是我读这个小说关注的是它很多，
我觉得显比吧，
就是那种很湿性的瞬间，
就像这个小说一开头，
这个小女孩，
她爸爸送她去这个寄养家庭的时候，
她躺在车后座上，
然后她就透过这个车窗看到外面的天空，
就说有的时候是蓝天和树木的组合，
有的时候是变线，
把蓝天分隔成一格一格的，
我觉得这个完全就像一首，
比如说新博斯卡的诗，
是一个很湿性的瞬间，
就它也对这个小说的情节。
没有什么特别的贡献，
但是让我非常的着迷。
太好了，
真的都在这个短短的小说里面，
读出了不同的切面，
因为我觉得小焦讲的那种湿性的瞬间，
那些显比，
也是它非常好看的地方，
我的那个感受是因为，
我会觉得它里面，
每一个行为或者每一个感受，
它都是有一定的因果性的，
就是你能够在这个很小的篇幅里面，
感受到很多丰富的情绪，
而且这些情绪是有来头的。
是的，是的，
同意细细说的确实是这样。
它每一个细节之后，
都会展现在一个故事的更深处，
所以也是老元说的，
就像进入荣动一样。
那我们就给听众朋友们来讲讲这个故事吧，
开头非常的简单，
它是这么写的，
一个星期天的一大早，
在克朗格尔坐完第一次迷洒后，
父亲没有送我回家，
而是开车深入维克斯福德，
前往母亲家乡的海岸，
那是一个炎热的夏天，
路上有一片片绿音，
还有突然闪现的光亮。
接着呢，
他就跟着父亲来到了，
这个母亲的亲戚家，
金塞拉夫妇一家，
然后这个女孩就在金塞拉夫妇家，
住了一个夏天，
住了几个月，
得到了金塞拉夫妇很细腻的照料，
那这个小说里面也有很多细腻的描写，
不仅是关于他们之间的对话，
还有一些物质的细节，
比如说墙纸啊，水井啊，衣服啊，
看起来都很日常，
但是呢，读完之后又会发现，
这些细节也展现了，
这个孩子原来过着怎样的生活，
他在原生家庭里面，
受到什么样的待遇和照料，
而到了金塞拉家之后，
又经历了什么变化，
所以我就想请大家，
选一段你们印象深刻的，
他描述养育照料这个过程的这样一个片段，
他在这个金塞拉家过着怎样的生活，
我印象最深的就是这个金塞拉和这个小女孩，
这个整个小说里面这个我，
这个小女孩是没有名字的，
所以就是我印象最深的就是金塞拉和这个小女孩，
牵手的一个片段，
我先给听众朋友们读一下，
这个片段很短，
如果你放到现实生活中的话，
可能他就是两三分钟内发生的事情，
他刚一牵起我的手，
我就意识到，
父亲一次也没有牵过我的手，
我内心隐约希望金塞拉把我放开，
让我不再有这种感觉，
这种感觉太难受了，
可是走着走着，
我的心安定下来，
不再去想，
我在家里的生活和在这里的生活有什么不同，
他布子卖的比较小，
让我们俩能够同步，
我想到小木屋里那个女人，
想到她走路和说话的样子，
我得出结论，
人与人之间有着天壤之别，
到了十字路口，
我们向右转，
走在一条很陡的下坡路上，
风呼啸着吹过高高的树梢，
焦躁的撕扯刚哭的树枝，
树叶在翻腾摇摆，
开阔的道路在脚下渐渐消失，
我们知道路的尽头就是大海，
路还在继续天空，
以及所有的一切，
似乎都变得明亮起来，
我觉得这段真的写得很好。
谢谢太好了，
大家里面就有很多对比，
牵起我的手，
我就感觉到父亲一次也没有牵起过我的手，
而且我特别喜欢他的一个描述是，
他希望金赛拉把他的手放开，
因为他说这种感觉太难受了，
这个是很细微的一个动差，
就是你突然被照顾，
被呵护，
你一下子会觉得很不适应，
你不会觉得太好了，
原来爱是这样的，
你反而会觉得说天呐，
这个是我不熟悉的一个动作，
不熟悉的一种爱意，
让我觉得很害怕，很慌张。
哎,
我觉得希希你一个说的太好了，
就是这一段我自己的感觉，
当然我不懂，我不懂文学，
你懂，你懂，
我所谓了，我懂不懂，
但是我感受到了他的美，
这就是最重要的，
我印象最深的就是，
牵手的这个动作，
金赛拉牵起我的手，
我觉得真的有一种像魔法一样的感觉，
他怎么能捕捉到一个瞬间，
这个瞬间不仅属于，
他牵起我的手发生的这一刻，
他也属于过去，也属于未来，
我在那一刻，
同时我想到过去，
这个说太好了，
对，我爸从来没有牵过我的手，
然后我的过去是一片空白，
而这个现在也改变了我的未来，
因为我很快就适应了，
这种被照顾的感受，
我不再去想那些过去的事情，
我感到心安，
而且我读这一段的时候，
这里面没有任何让我觉得说，
非常少见的词汇，
或者说非常让我觉得，
我完全是意料不到的动作，
意料不到的感受，
然后他的情绪也很简单，
就是短短的两个自然段，
可是他的情绪就从，
我的这种慌张，
然后到被撫平，
然后到后面说，
我突然觉得道路也开阔了，
我似乎一切都变得明亮下来，
就你能感觉到，
通过这个景色的描写，
感觉到这个女孩的心，
也松动了，也安定下来了，
然后周遭的景色，
也随着她的心情发生了变化，
就只是两个自然段，
然后她的情绪，
就有这么翻天覆地的变化，
但她又那么的自然，
我真的感觉这就是魔法，
跟迪士尼一样，
是的,
而且我觉得，
吉根确实把这个牵手当成了，
她这部小说的最高光的时刻，
其实这个看上去，
比较平常的一个片段，
已经是这个小说的高光时刻了，
所以结尾的时候，
她又写了一个牵手，
就是这种，
身体接触拥抱的瞬间吧，
我觉得是呼应这个牵手的瞬间的，
所以其实，
这样的时刻，
已经是这个小说，
吉根想要格外，
浓墨重彩的一笔，
我觉得老远选的特别好，
对我印象深刻的片段，
接在老远说的这一段的前面，
为什么他们会有这一次牵手，
为什么会有这一次对话，
其实是，
之前发生的一些事情，
这个金赛拉夫妇呢，
带着小女孩去守林，
有一个人去世了，
他们带着她去守林，
然后看这个小女孩无聊了，
就拜托另外一个，
应该是邻居，
还是同村的女人，
先带女孩回去，
然后路上呢，
这个女人就一直在，
问小女孩很多的问题，
在窥探金赛拉一家的隐私，
故意向她揭露金赛拉家里的秘密，
这个秘密就是说，
他们其实曾经有过一个孩子，
但是这个孩子意外死亡了，
这个9岁的小女孩，
就在路上跟一个不太熟的人，
接受到了很多这样的信息，
其实她的内心是非常复杂的，
而且我们也说了，
她是一个很敏感的小孩，
但是呢，她具体是怎么想的，
是怎么处理这些信息的，
小说也没有展开去写，
那后来金赛拉就知道了这件事情，
所以才决定带小女孩出去走走，
走到海边，
就有了刚才老员说的那个牵手的一幕，
小说是这样写的，
他们在海边，
金赛拉说，
知道吗，
渔民有时会在海上发现马，
我认识一个男人，
他有一次拖上来一匹小马，
马躺了很久才站起来，
那匹马没什么毛病，
只是累了，
在海上漂泊了那么久，
总会发生一些奇怪的事，
他说,
你今晚就遇到一件怪事，
你永远不需要说什么，
时刻记住，
这是你永远没必要做的事，
许多人损失惨重，
就是因为没有把握住，
保持沉默的好机会，
这个夜晚的一切都很奇怪，
走向一片始终存在的大海，
在半明半暗中目睹他，
感受他，害怕他，
听这个男人说海上的马，
说一些我不能完全理解的事，
甚至也许不是说给我听的事，
这个时候，
他张开双臂抱住我，
把我拦入怀中，
如同我是他的亲生孩子。
写的真的很好，
这一段话，
就是小焦之前讲的一个失信的语言，
我觉得这一句话，
你知道吗，
余民有时候会在海上发现马，
这一句话，
就会让我觉得，
你其实具体的意思，
我也不是完全理解的。
我觉得你说特别对，
回到小焦讲的这个失信语言，
我在想，
他讲的这个话是很不日常的，
他不是关于一个生活中的事情，
他也没有直接的去回应说，
哎，这个女人跟你说了这些话，
你不要听，你不要管，
或者说我家里其实发生了什么，
我就写到这里，
可能很多人都会顺着往那个地方写，
所以他这个语言上是有很多的失忆的，
但是我又觉得，
他保持了一种生活中的精准，
在这个时候，
你不知道该说什么，
但是不知道说什么的时候，
说出的话，
却展现了极大的包容和温柔。
我觉得极根的小说，
他在平淡中有一种，
环环相扣的精妙，
这段对话，
就是金塞拉说，
哎，渔民有时候会在海上发现吗？
包括他后面跟他说，
你可以保持沉默，
就让我想到，
小女孩刚刚到金塞拉家时，
她的一个观察，
因为她很快呢，
就观察到，
这里跟自己家不同，
她说在自己家呢，
每个人都过着很匆忙，
潦草,
也不会想太多的这样的生活，
他们只是在过日子，
日复一日的过，
然后她写了一句话，
她说,
但这个家风格不一样，
这里地方比较宽敞，
有时间想心事，
甚至可能还有多余的钱，
她在那个英文版里写的是，
here there is room and time to think,。
就是think,。
这个想，
这个空间和时间，
去思考，
去想心事，
这个就是她小女孩的角度，
捕捉到的一个巨大的差异，
因为我们讲，
这是一个关于养育的小说，
就养育其实就是需要很多的，
养育,
很多的空间，
去想，去观照，
因为海边这一幕，
就是一个年长者，
他关注到了小孩的异样的感受，
他想要想办法，
用语言和行动，
让他知道，
但又不让他觉得很难受，
或者说，
信息轰炸，
给他太多的东西，
所以他讲海上的马，
讲这些故事，
讲这些有点零散的片段，
好像就是为了告诉这个女孩说，
我跟你是一伙的，
我是你这边的，
所以就像老元说的，
就是对这样一个
敏感聪慧的女孩，
这样的动作，
这样的话语，
她既是跟过去连结，
又是通向未来的，
就是有这样一个一夜晚，
会对她之后的人生，
都留下一些印记。
那小娇，你最喜欢哪一段？
对，我觉得老元和希希选的，
都是这个书里面，
比较特别的一些段落，
就是有一些情节张力的段落，
心里活动也比较多，
我选的这一段呢，
是对她整个这个暑假的日常描写，
是这样写的，
日子就这样一天天过去，
我一直在等待什么事发生，
等待我感觉到的，
这种安逸，
假然而止，
在尿湿的床上醒来，
犯了某个错误，
床下某种大货，
打碎了什么东西，
但是每一天，
都像前一天一样继续着，
太阳一出来，
我们就早早起床，
饭吃各种做法的鸡蛋，
配烤面包和果酱，
饭后金塞拉戴上帽子，
去外面的院子里，
我和金塞拉太太大声说出，
需要干的活，
然后就一箭箭的去做，
我们拔大黄，做蛋塔，
粉刷踢脚板，
把所有的贝入，
从烘干柜里拿出来，
用吸尘器打扫蜘蛛网，
把干净衣服全部收回去，
做司康饼，
擦洗浴缸，
扫楼梯，拋光家具，
把洋葱熬成洋葱酱，
盛在容器里放入冰箱，
拿出花潭的杂草，
当太阳落山时，
给各种东西浇水，
接着就是料理晚饭，
走过田野，
到下面的景边去，
每天晚上打开电视，
看九点钟的新闻，
到天气预报播完之后，
我被吩咐上床睡觉，
其实从这一段看起来，
这个小女孩的夏天也挺辛苦的，
也并不是优惡安逸的生活，
但是就是这种，
每天做了很多工作的，
这样一天，
已经是这个小女孩。
能够想象到的美好生活了。
我也喜欢一些极根写的细节，
比如说，
她说早饭吃各种做法的鸡蛋，
加上这个各种做法，
我自己还在想，
有哪些做法可以做鸡蛋呢？
因为有很多，对吧？
因为我不会做饭，
sorry!
就是，不是，
你去点那个brunch，
她不就会说吗？
你要scramble,。
然后 sunny,。
side up,。
然后什么各种对？
就是,
感觉确实也是普通的食物，
但努力的，
每一天都不一样，
做的很丰富，
就是,
一种挺好的生活的感觉吧？
我和金萨拉太太大声说出，
需要干的活，
然后一件一件去做，
给人感觉，
就是充实有节奏的生活，
不会漫无目的，
没有抱怨，
也没有秘密，
我感觉，
就哪怕给今天的我们，
觉得我早上大声说出要干的事，
然后一件一件的干完，
然后出去散步，
去景边，
然后晚上看一会儿电视，
上床睡觉，
就是这种节奏感也让人很向往，
这一段是向往的生活，
有节律的向往的生活似的，
其实我们刚刚聊了一点，
小女孩在金萨拉家的生活体验，
然后这个体验呢，
是跟她之前，
跟自己的父母，
还有很多的兄弟姐妹，
住在一起，
那个体验很不一样的，
她一开头就有一句话，
是女孩的亲生父亲，
跟金萨拉夫妇说的，
她说,
她能吃，
但你们可以派她干活，
she will eat,。
but you can work her,。
这个是那个小说里面写的，
这句话就是，
比较残酷的一句话，
这个亲生父亲，
几乎就是说，
她是一个劳动力，
她会吃掉你们的一些食物，
但是你可以，
让她做一些工作，
但是呢，
这个没有血缘的金萨拉夫妇，
却在生活中，
真正的照顾她，
尊重她，
在月下跟她谈心事，
牵住她的手，
所以我觉得，
这个小说，
也是在讨论，
养育和血缘之间的，
这种关系，
怎么样，
才算是家人呢？
刚才,
西西,
前面有一段话，
我觉得，
让我听的，
其实挺感触的，
她就说，
养育需要富裕，
这个富裕，
不光是金钱上的，
可能还有精神上的，
小说本身写的也非常少，
这是对她这个，
原生家庭的描述，
因为她始终是，
在用一种对比嘛，
那个原生家庭，
她不用写，
但是她每一次，
对这个新家庭的，
这种反应，
你都能想象到，
她的原生家庭，
是非常匮乏，
非常没有爱，
也没有安全感，
然后我看完这个小说，
我就在想说，
那什么是好的养育呢？
现在网上，
经常会有一个论调，
说如果没钱，
就别生了，
我不知道对不对啊，
反正我没钱，
我是没生的，
但是我觉得，
这东西就会让我，
会好奇，
到底什么叫好的养育，
我感觉啊，
血缘和养育，
这其实是在亲情，
里面一个，
非常有张力的话题，
而且很多，
很厉害的艺术家，
用这个为话题，
创作了非常多，
很好的故事，
或者很好的艺术作品，
比如说我有一个，
挺喜欢的电影，
就是那个小偷家族，
小偷家族，
也是拿了，
Gana的金宗旅嘛，
他讲的就是说，
他们不是，
真正的亲人嘛，
但是他们生活在一起，
里面有一句台词，
大概就是说，
难道有血缘，
那才是亲人吗？
难道人不应该，
可以选择自己的亲人吗？
所以我就在想说，
到底什么样，
才算亲人呢？
其实我也不知道，
我也没有答案。
你刚才说，
没钱,
就不要生了，
就是在这个故事里面，
亲生父亲，
说的是，
你就用它吧，
you can work her,。
她用的是work，
作为一个动词嘛，
但是呢，
金塞拉夫妇说的是什么呢？
就是她住了几天以后，
那个金塞拉太太就说，
啊，小女孩，
你的气色好多了，
all you need is minding,。
就是她用了这个minding，
这个动词，
就是照料，
电机,
想着,
所以我在想，
她说的这种养育的，
余育空间，
也不完全是只金钱，
而是说，
你会不会有这个空间，
有余育去照料这个人，
去电机这个人，
去真的在意她的感受，
我会觉得，
这个也是，
可能小说想要处理的一个主题，
就是什么叫做，
在乎,
什么叫做照料，
不过我觉得，
在这个小说里面，
其实还有一个背景，
就是像金塞拉家，
他们一起劳作呀，
生活的这种，
大家可以看到，
其实她是，
一个挺田园木哥的一个环境，
其实她是一个农场的这种环境，
在这种情况下，
其实无论人，
赋予余否，
她在时间上，
在空间上，
是宽愈的，
这个是一个前提，
就是room and time,。
是的,
但是就说，
刚刚老元说的这个，
也是在当今社会，
它不是一个绝对的真理，
但是有一定道理，
就说如果你生活在都市中，
你没有钱，
你真的是会，
也没有时间，
你真的是会疲于奔命，
你真的是会被体系吸进去，
你也没有空间，
你会住在很小的地方，
你也没有钱，
然后这样的话，
确实,
它会导致，
没有那个多余的，
脑力去mind，
去惦记，
想着养育孩子，
我其实一直对这个话题，
也是挺感兴趣的，
因为我自己，
研究有一个很感兴趣的，
词就是这个，
共同体的概念，
其实我自己，
之所以对这个概念，
感兴趣，
有一个很大的原因，
就是我非常好奇，
人都可以，
以什么样的方式，
聚集在一起，
共同生活，
回到这个小说，
我也做了一点点的功课，
他就说，
其实中世纪的爱尔兰，
是有寄养孩子的传统的，
也有法律规定，
布雷红法，
他把这个寄养，
还就是分成了两种，
一种叫，
为爱的寄养，
为爱寄养，
就是因为爱，
是不收费的，
还有一种，
就是有收费标准的寄养，
而且,
在这个有收费标准的寄养里面，
女孩的寄养费会更高，
原因就是，
女孩更难养，
日后的用处更小，
这个是法律里面的原话，
刚刚希希提到，
好几次那个很重要的，
就是他父亲说，
他能吃，
但是你们也可以派他干活，
你可以work her，
对吧,
你可以让他去劳作，
就这种把女孩当成，
劳动力的思想，
其实逻辑跟中世纪小女孩，
作为劳动力，
用处更小的逻辑是一样的，
但这个小说，
让我们很喜欢的地方就是，
虽然他亲生父亲是这么想，
但是,
最后他在这个寄养的家庭，
得到的是，
这个中世纪里面说的这个爱的寄养，
他得到的是关照，
所以我觉得就是亲人和家人，
这个是我自己的看法，
我觉得是两个概念，
就是亲人是既有血缘关系，
又有共同生活的人，
所以这个亲，
这个词在亲人里面的亲，
他一方面是血亲的亲，
一方面是亲近的亲，
你又在共同的空间生活，
并且你还有血缘关系是亲人，
但是家人，
我认为是，
只要在同一个共同空间生活的人，
你把这个共同空间称作家，
你一起吃饭，
同住在一个屋檐下，
日常照料，
一起散步，
我觉得就可以变成家人，
所以金赛拉加，
就是靠这些洗澡，
吃饭,
景边打水，
牵手,
就是这些重复性的。
共同生活的经历，
把一个外来的孩子，
我觉得是变成了家人，
这种截律，
其实他也建构出了一种，
家的这种紧然的秩序，
这种感觉，
刚刚老元和希希都提到，
就是说，
这本小说一直在对比，
可以看到，
小女孩原生家庭的感觉，
就是鸡飞狗跳，
因为有好多小孩，
她母亲又有了新生儿，
小女孩的原生家庭，
其实是失序的，
是没有节奏的，
就是大家都大吵大闹，
在那种环境里，
即使是亲人，
有血缘关系，
也生活在一个屋檐下，
但是其实是没有家的感觉的，
但是他在这个金赛拉证，
他有紧然有序的感觉，
他有节奏，
有生活的质感，
所以家真的其实是。
脱离于血清之外，
而且其实这种家可大可小，
这种共同体的感觉，
我个人认为，
未来世界也更需要。
人们去重新想象的一种可能，
对，你说家的这个截律，
我觉得太有感受了，
我一回家就要吃三顿，
对，都是正经的一顿，
就不可能很潦草，
这个也是家的温暖，
也是一种束缚，
就是家就是有规矩，
没有规矩不成方圆，
是的，你刚刚讲的，
就是说什么是家人，
这种共同生活的体验，
就让我想到，
日剧《四重奏》里面的一句名台词，
宗庸子演的这个女生，
就跟满岛光说，
他说，虽然我们不是亲人，
也没有血缘关系，
但我们的头发散发着同样的香味，
用着同一种洗发水，
衣服混在一起洗，
我想，那里就是小雀你的容身之所呀，
因为她里面也是，
几个没有血缘关系的人聚在了一起，
他们不仅共同生活，
还组成了一个四重奏乐团，
满岛光誓言的那个小女孩，
她也是从小就被父亲，
卷入诈骗和骗局当中，
她的原生家庭也是非常破碎，
非常失序，充满谎言的，
这几个各自有伤痛，
各自有点古怪的人，
因为音乐结缘聚在一起，
所以我觉得就是完美解释了，
小娇刚刚讲的这种，
共同生活建立起来的，
共同体和亲密的感觉。
我还记得，
这里面还有一个，
大家要有一些，
在这个小群体里面的共识，
比如说让人印象深刻的，
就是吃炸鸡，
还是什么，
要不要把那个柠檬撒在上面，
大家都要在餐桌上讨论，
达成共识，
就是这种也是共同体生活，
家庭能达成的一些瞬间，
就是说我们要讨论，
我们怎么一起生活，
因为我们要一起吃饭，
我们要一起生活，
噪音之类的，
就是这些细小的瞬间，
文学作品里面能捕捉到，
影视作品里能捕捉到，
也确实像我们展现了，
当你不是家人，
你没有一个大家长，
你重新想象，
共同生活的方式和规矩的时候，
这些小的瞬间也挺迷人的。
我觉得想象这个说的太好了，
对我还挺有启发的，
我想到有一个英国女导演，
阿诺德，
就是拍于刚和美国填新的那个导演，
他有一个短片，
叫黄峰，是拿乐，
好像是03年的奥斯卡，
最佳的真人短片，
然后那个短片拍的真的也很不错，
他就讲一个单亲妈妈，
然后他有很多问题，
他也有好几个孩子，
但是他有好几个孩子的情况下，
他还是非常渴望爱情，
所以他就要去约会，
简单来说他不是一个好的母亲，
也不是常规议的一个好的女人，
但是在1%的关键时刻，
然后他保持了理智，
然后克服了自己的私欲，
他做出了一个算是好母亲的选择嘛，
小焦讲的时候，
我就想到说，
OK，他不是一个好的妈妈，
他也不会是一个好的养育者，
但这是爱嘛，
我觉得这种问题，
其实在我看这个小说的时候，
也一直营绕着我，
就想说，
如果一个人他爱自己的儿女，
但是他却没有办法好好地养育他，
因为各种原因，
他不一定是发心就是很邪恶，
他就是没有那个能力，
这种父母真的是太多了，
我在想，
这到底什么才算是爱呢，
就这个小小的问题一直营绕着我，
但是我觉得就是小焦讲的，
这种我们重新构建一个家庭，
然后我们重新对非常非常小的事情，
不管是像我们今天聊的这个小说收留，
还是聊到四重奏，
我们都重新去定义他，
然后达成一个共识，
我不知道这算不算爱，
但是我非常向往这种生活，
我觉得在我心中，
这个可能就算是爱吧。
我想稍微补充一点，
袁刚刚讲的，
我觉得为什么这个收留，
写的让我们都这么地动容，
就是他写的原生家庭，
并不是一个邪恶的地方，
不是说，
真的就是父母都要害我，
父母都是要把我卖了，
为了什么生一个弟弟，
就是他也没有写这种意义上的一个。
惨痛的原生家庭，
他的这个原生家庭，
更多的是老元说的顾不上，
而且结合当时艾尔兰的这个背景，
小说发生在1981年，
在艾尔兰这个避孕，
是80年代以后才合法的，
就是你在那之前你是不能避孕的，
所以他有怀上了，
他就得生，
在这个故事里面，
小女孩的亲生母亲，
在这个故事的开始，
大着肚子，
要生一个弟弟，
结果在故事的结尾几个月后，
他生完了弟弟，
他又怀孕了，
而且艾尔兰也比较特殊嘛，
他们就是受天主教会影响很大的国家，
所以刚才说的避孕，
到了80年代之后才合法，
然后12周内的墮胎，
是经历了很漫长的挣扎，
到了2018年才完全合法的，
在那之前，
他们想要墮胎，
可能要跑到英国去，
所以就是在这样一个，
非常特殊的地点和时期背景下，
很多家庭，
这种多子的，
贫穷的家庭，
他对于孩子就是，
没有办法去mind，
他根本就顾不上，
不是说家长满怀着爱意说，
哦，我要养育一个孩子，
我要做好为人父母的准备，
他很多就是说，
哎，孩子又来了，又来了，
小娇也讲了，
就是他的原生家庭是失序的是，
鸡飞狗跳的是，
每个人都顾不上的，
每个人都觉得自己，
被迫呆在了这里，
来到了这个位置。
所以我觉得，
刚刚老元的问题，
就是说，
什么是爱？
爱是怎样的？
到西西说的，
爱尔兰的这个社会环境，
就是这种天主教国家，
在避孕呀，
墮胎呀，
上面法律变更的治后，
其实也让我想到，
就是说，
确实,
这个也是我们很多时候说的，
这个爱，
其实是要有一个社会环境，
才能建立的好多时候，
一个母亲，
她不是说，
我自发的很爱这个孩子，
但是我也没有生机，
然后我还得出去打好几份工，
对吧,
那我拿什么来爱这个孩子？
但是如果，
相对来说，
有一个脚位安稳的，
社会环境，
能给一个单亲妈妈，
比如说提供更好的福利，
也许这个单亲妈妈，
她少打一份工，
她就能有那个余力，
去多爱一点这个孩子，
然后就包括整体，
像西西提到这个，
我觉得特别好，
就是社会的保守程度呀，
法律的这个结构呀，
其实都对我们怎么理解爱，
包括就是说，
一个国家的意识形态，
你认不认为，
家长需要跟孩子，
去商讨一些事情，
来定立这个规矩，
而不是你，
指定让孩子去做一些事，
对吧,
其实这个也是一个，
文化的一个infrastructure，
一个基础设施，
这个也是爱生长的根基，
如果你那个根基，
就是一个控制的根基，
那就很难在这个上面，
长出健康的爱的话读。
所以人，
天然有亲人，
但是人不是天然有家人，
家是需要构建的。
天呐,
你这句话出来了，
我们这个标题有了，
标题。
刚刚老元讲的，
就说,
如果小时候没有被，
好好的爱过，
你真的，
会有这个能力，
来建立新的关系，
建立良好的爱吗？
就这个小说的结尾，
也让我们看得非常动容，
他其实也是在讨论说，
这样一次，
下日的继扬，
到底会在一个人身上留下什么？
这个结尾是这样写的，
女孩呢，
与金塞拉夫妇分别之后，
她回到了自己的家，
然后呢，
在这个金塞拉要离开的时候，
女孩,
追着跑出去，
扑到了金塞拉的怀里，
与此同时，
她也看见自己的父亲，
往这边走，
她知道自己就要分离了，
就要回归自己的家庭了，
然后这个时候，
女孩说了，
两句爸爸，
我说着，
爸爸,
我提醒她，
这个她是金塞拉，
我呼唤她，
爸爸,
所以呢，
在最后，
也是有这样一个，
小小的高潮，
一个,
比较害羞，
被动,
敏感的女孩，
追出去，
跟她的，
继扬家庭的，
这个金塞拉拥抱，
并且,
称她为爸爸，
你们怎么看，
这样一个结局？
你们觉得这个是个，
happy ending,。
就是,
她感受到了，
一个下日，
充沛的，
爱的滋养呢，
还是一个bad ending，
就是她又回到了，
自己的原生家庭。
我看这个段的时候，
我有一个特别大的触动，
就是，这个，
即跟小说，
最触动我的地方，
我觉得她真的好厉害，
她总能找到一个，
非常复杂的，
一个瞬间，
就这个瞬间，
真的是，
悲伤与幸福共存的，
一个瞬间，
从情节来看，
我觉得这个，
一定是一个，
坏的结局，
我看到中间，
我就会想说，
啊，你金塞拉夫妇，
别走了，
对，那么好，对吧，
你就抢夺她的抚养权，
对吧，你就说，
我也没孩子，
你就把她带走，
然后那个，
原生家庭向她要钱，
这就变成那个，
短句的剧情，
对，给你三吨骨子，
然后就打发了，对吧，
在我看来，
这才是美好的结局，
但是呢，
我又觉得，
从未来来看，
从成长的角度来看，
这是一个，
好的结局，
因为,
这是女孩，
第一次主动，
表达她的爱，
就她奔向金塞拉夫妇，
我觉得，
这已经，
可以证明，
她知道，
爱是什么，
然后她也，
知道怎么表达，
而我觉得，
这种,
知道真的是，
没有办法，
没有任何人，
可以收回的，
然后可能，
金塞拉夫妇，
只是她，
理解爱，
表达爱，
中间的一战，
但是这一战呢，
就是因为，
开了一个，
很好的头，
所以就走向了正轨，
你可以想象，
如果这个女孩，
就在这个，
原来的家庭成长，
我觉得，
她对爱的理解，
一定是，
这个感触，
就是这个，
极根真的很厉害，
她找到了一个，
非常非常复杂的瞬间，
刚刚你讲的，
接收到爱，
辨别爱，
同时,
最后这个动作，
好像又是，
给出爱的，
这样一个感觉，
这个,
学习是，
学会了，
就再也忘不掉的嘛，
就像学自行车一样，
就算你生输了，
就算你回到了你的，
糟糕的原生家庭，
但是,
一上手，
就能唤醒记忆嘛，
其实,
现在,
你们三个，
都没有做父母嘛，
都没有孩子，
我觉得在讨论，
养育这个话题呢，
我们也都是，
想到哪里，
说哪里，
但是我觉得，
养育这个话题，
其实会有很多，
比较,
两极的看法，
有一种，
就觉得，
哇孩子怎么样，
就是怎么样，对吧，
你不管怎么养，
他有自己的路要走，
但是另外一种，
就会觉得说，
好像你，
稍有不注意，
那个孩子，
如此的敏感，
他可能，
那一瞬间的，
冷淡,
很大的伤害，
就是这个，
做父母，
可能会过分小心，
所以,
我觉得，
这里面就有，
很有意思的问题，
人到底是，
怎么在养育，
和被养育当中，
感受到爱的，
这个东西，
它是一个技能，
还是一种天性。
我特别喜欢，
小娇刚才讲的那个，
想象力，
对家庭的想象力，
我觉得，
这个爱，
没有标准答案，
也不是说，
金塞拉夫妇，
给予的答案，
就是标准答案，
但是,
这个东西，
都像你见过龙一样，
你见过龙，
你相信这个世界上有龙，
所以,
你看到独角兽的时候，
你觉得这玩意，
也应该是真的，
但是,
如果你被剥夺了，
那种想象力，
你觉得这个世界，
没有爱，
你只有看到痛苦的时候，
你觉得，
啊,
这才是真的，
我这才回家了，
这才是我的家，
这才让我安心，
那完蛋了，
所以,
我认为，
金塞拉夫妇，
给予他的，
就是打开了，
他的想象力，
这样一种，
让我舒服的方式，
我可以跟他们共存，
我觉得，
这个是很重要的。
这个问题特别好，
就是,
有没有一种，
正确的爱的方式，对吧？
你说,
你给予他很多的爱，
还是孩子，
他就怎么都长大了，
你怎么养他，
他都会长成，
他应该长成的样子，对吧？
就是这个，
这个叫什么，
宿命论，
我有一个，
个人观点，
完全是出于一个，
我自己小的时候，
是一个，
极其高明感，
小孩的感受，
我觉得爱，
就是,
抓住和放手，
是同一个东西，
这两面，
你都做到了，
才实。
哇,
好好好。
拥有和，
放弃,
是同一个东西，
当你做到，
一切你能做到的，
但与此同时，
给他自由，
让他选择，
该放手的时候，
放手。
这也太难了吧，
这也太难了，
我做不到，
没有没有，
这个就是我想象中的，
最好的东西嘛，
不光是养育，
其实我们都说，
一个共同体，
无论是大到国家，
还是小到一个，
一个小共同体，
宗教组织，
你想要让这个群体，
有凝聚力，
你就要定很多的规则，
你就要让它非常的狂热，
但与此同时，
你如果到了一个极端，
它就会变成，
纳粹德国，对吧，
一个狂热的，
攻击者，
但是如果，
你让大家既有爱，
然后又有，
比如说，
像理论家们说的，
Days of Hate,。
就是 Unworked Community,。
他们在情感上，
是联系在一起的，
但是这个共同体，
它又不是，
被紧紧的，
绑在一起，
无法松开，
它又是一个 Unworked，
它又是一个，
松散的，
所以就是，
大到一个国家，
小到一个，
养育孩子和家庭，
它都要在，
爱和放手中间，
都做到，
它才是一个，
完美的集合，
如果你只有，
紧紧抓住的爱，
或者是你完全放手，
都会有，
不同方向的，
极端的走向，
那我理解，
这个爱，
真的就像，
交旗自行车一样，
因为我觉得，
我小时候，
我爸教我，
旗自行车，
就是,
他一定要放手，
但是他要，
让你知道，
你摔倒的时候，
他会,
接住你，
吃的,
我觉得，
刚刚聊完，
还是很多的感触，
而且,
吉根,
他自己也有，
这种,
收留,
寄养的，
精力,
我听了他的一个，
播客的访谈，
然后他17岁的时候呢，
就遇到了一个，
美国家庭，
为什么他们，
想要赞助你呢？
吉根说，
因为我是个，
很好的帮手，
会照顾孩子，
也会做家务，
就这个答案，
跟小说里面，
父亲的台词，
几乎是一模一样的，
他是有一种，
很清醒的，
对自己功能的认知，
吉根自己的母亲，
跟这个美国家庭，
只通了一通电话，
他就去美国了，
也没有什么，
太多的沟通，
他是母亲的第六个孩子，
而且呢，
母亲还有很多事情要做，
还在跟父亲，
分居啊，
有不幸福的婚姻，
所以根本管不上，
说孩子要干嘛，
说你想去美国读书，
有人能够，
为你承担这些费用，
那你去吧，
所以他是在美国，
新尔良的这个，
Loyola University,。
读了文学和政治学，
然后七年后，
才回到的爱尔兰，
所以就是在想说，
收养啊，寄养，
这也是他自己的一个，
亲身经历，
所以我觉得他写出来的时候，
也会有很多，
很真实的观察，
我觉得总体读这本小说，
如果说是，
happy ending,。
还是bad ending,。
我觉得几根还是，
给我们很多，
乐观和希望的，
谁给你爱这件事情，
并没有那么大的关系，
他不见得，
一定要是你的亲生父母，
只要你在年轻的时候，
被挂念，
被爱,
被照料，
学会了如何，
给予关爱，
就大概不会变成，
一个太糟糕的大人。
人们说学习爱，
我还是挺喜欢这个词的，
他其实有一个learning curve，
他有一个学习过程，
但是他是真的可以被习得的，
不是说你没有，
你就永远不会再有了，
你的原生家庭没有给你爱，
你就再也不会有了，
并不是的，
只要你把它当成一个。
可以学习的东西，
你尝试这一不同的方式，
给别人一些关爱，
试试看，
看一看人们的反馈，
很有可能在这些过程中，
慢慢你就交到了
很好的朋友，
你找到了，
你自己的共同体小圈子，
你也就能收到爱，
在这个过程中，
就像四重奏里面，
那些破碎的，
失败的人，
小偷家庭里面那些，
也穷困潦倒，
但是生活在一起的人，
也在这个过程中，
找到了爱嘛，
我觉得希希说的，
特别对，
就是吉根，
他是一个，
底色乐观的作家，
在这个小说里面，
你看到的人，
都是挺好的人，
而且其实想一想，
这个故事里面的，
吉塞拉夫妇，
是有很严重的，
创伤的，
整个小镇里的人，
都切切私语他们的创伤，
你要说，
一个家庭，
受到了这么大的，
创伤独生子，
去世了，
就是应该会是，
风心所爱的状态吧，
但是他们也没有，
重新拿出来，
把爱给了另外一个小孩，
人是有能力突破，
一些局限，
然后克服一些创伤，
重新来，
找到自己爱的方式的。
那我们再聊聊，
吉根作为一个作家的，
比法,
因为我们都讲了，
我们还是，
非常喜欢这个小说的，
首先我觉得，
收留这个小说呢，
他是一个，
非常平淡的小说，
他没有任何的，
强情节，
强冲突，
或者多少秒一个反转，
不是那种，
欧亨历世的短篇小说，
让这一，
居然是这样的，
但是,
他在写这种，
日常的，
微小的时刻当中，
又让人感觉到了，
很震撼人心的东西，
那么,
这种,
写法的魔力是什么？
我不知道，
怎么来衡量，
吉根的一个小说的，
淡和浓，
但我自己有一个，
土理论，
就是我自己的这个，
土法链刚的一个理论，
我觉得一个好的故事，
应该是，
复杂的人物，
和简单的情节，
但是呢，
我看过太多电影，
是简单的人物，
和复杂的情节，
用一堆情节，
堆砌我，
早就知道的信息，
我在里面，
没有任何悬念的感觉，
虽然他的情节，
花里不少，
但是从我走进电影院，
第一分钟，
我就知道，
后面是什么了，
结局是什么了，
我在那个，
和跟他在一起，
互动的感觉，
但是我觉得，
极根的这个小说，
虽然他写的如此平淡，
我觉得听众朋友们，
如果听到这儿的话，
其实你已经，
完全知道这个故事，
发生的内容是什么了，
但是,
当你真的去阅读的时候，
你还是有一种，
全念的感觉，
在做拼图的感觉，
我就说里面的一个细节，
这个细节，
让我印象很深，
就讲说这个，
小女孩儿，
第一次来金赛，
拉夫妇的家里，
写的是，
里面有一张，
大双人床，
上面铺着，
竹心沙，
床单,
床的两边，
都有台灯，
我知道，
这是他们睡觉的地方，
出于某种原因，
我很高兴，
他们睡在一起，
通过这一句话，
你就能想到，
他原来的家庭生活，
家庭条件，
和家庭氛围，
是什么样子的，
以及这两个家庭的对比，
他对于爱，
和正常家庭的渴望，
这么多的信息，
都浓缩在这短短的，
半句话里面，
而这句话，
又是如此的，
平淡和简单，
出于某种原因，
我很高兴，
他们睡在一起，
所以我真的觉得，
这就是，
魔法,
而且,
这是真正的悬念，
这个悬念，
是关于人物的，
关于这个人，
真正内心渴望的。
我觉得你说的太好了，
我想问，
你觉得，
这个故事里面的，
悬念是什么，
比如说，
这个小说，
我们比较明显的，
一个悬念，
暑假之后，
女孩会不会，
留下来，
就是她这个，
寄养,
她会不会，
变成一个，
永久的收养，
这可能是，
一个事件上的悬念，
但是,
我自己在读的时候，
我觉得，
这也不是，
能够,
让我看下去的，
一个原因，
吸引我看下去的是，
老元刚刚讲的，
这个小女孩，
她能不能，
在这个新的环境中，
真的放松下来，
如果说，
改变了，
到底是，
发生了什么，
会让她的感受，
改变,
甚至比如说，
是最有戏剧性的，
一个桥段，
然后这个邻居说，
你知道吗，
他们家里以前发生过，
什么什么样的事情，
就感觉是一个，
比较戏剧张力的时刻，
但是呢，
你的心，
稍微掉起来，
但很快，
她也没有什么反转，
也没有什么冲突，
就是一次，
月下的谈话，
又解决了，
小女孩又，
很快被这种，
善意包裹住了，
那在这个，
故事里面，
短片小说，
她是一种，
放大一个，
内心很小的，
瞬间的，
这样一个艺术吗，
就是,
她把,
人生中，
我们自己可能，
都没有意识到的，
决定性的瞬间，
来,
展开去写，
我特别想知道，
小娇怎么看，
来来来，
我没法回答这个问题，
因为我每一次，
打开一本书，
我就抢破证，
她再难看，
我把它看完了，
其实就是，
言着,
希希刚才说的，
说,
短片小说，
是放大瞬间的艺术吗，
是不是描绘一些，
人生中可能，
主人公都没有意识到的，
决定性的瞬间，
我觉得是的，
就是,
首先,
大家很多人会说，
特别是，
短片小说作家，
他们也会说，
短片小说，
其实是一个图画，
是一幅画面，
所以,
即跟她自己也说，
收留诞生于一个画面，
就是,
一只孩子的手，
印在一片，
静止不动的水面上，
所以,
其实是一个，
小说的来源，
是一个失性的一个画面，
然后,
她再把这个画面，
扩充成这个故事的时候，
给了老远说的，
这些人物，
非常丰富的，
故事,
和他们非常丰富的互动，
我觉得，
这个是，
短片小说，
和长片小说的差异，
因为长片小说，
是一个，
非常长的卷軸，对吧，
它在时间流动上，
是,
非常慢的，
但是,
短片小说，
在时间流动上，
节奏相对来说，
会非常快，
就像我刚刚，
开头读到的那一段，
就是他们日常，
劳作的那些，
重复的日子那么多，
他就用一段话总结了，
就是说，
日复一日，
我们干着这些事情，
然后非常平静，
我在想，
这样的日子，
什么时候会结束？
所以就是，
短片小说，
他在节奏上，
会非常快，
把时间压缩，
更像一幅画面，
展开的这种节奏感，
但于此同时，
也因为这个，
时间的节奏，
所以就是，
像长片小说，
他就会有，
有李希斯这样的小说，
一个人的一天，
他就写了，
那么厚的一本书，
对吧,
他在街上走，
也是爱尔兰人，
对，乔伊斯，
但是像这个，
就是把一个夏天，
简简单单的，
压缩在了，
很短的，
这个几十页当中，
所以,
你在这种情况下，
要更加地，
找到节奏感，
我觉得，
在画面，
这个展开之中，
小说的动作，
和停滞，
就是他流动的部分，
和他停滞的部分，
都要,
找到对的东西，
比如说，
牵手,
他就是一个，
非常短的瞬间，
扩充成了，
比较长的，
聚光灯，
照在的地方，
然后像，
日复一日的劳作，
他就,
变成了，
很短的，
像是静止的动作，
什么,
拔大黄，
做蛋塔，
刷地板，
吸尘,
就是所有这些，
虽然是动作，
但是他，
因为是重复的，
所以就有一种静止感，
时间在流动，
但是这些动作，
是重复的，
没有前进，
而真正的，
所谓的运动，
都是,
在这个，
静止的背景下，
所有的运动，
就被压到了，
这些瞬间，
但与此同时，
情感上，
又非常的浓烈，
比如说，
就是牵手，
他们之间的对话，
就变成了，
更重要的，
更让人，
触动的这些时间，
他融合在，
这个很短的，
短片小说里面，
把这个夏天，
的节奏，
就非常好的，
空斥在这个空间里面，
所以,
堵起来的时候，
也会觉得，
非常的，
张驰有度，
我觉得这个，
是他的小说，
至少从我的角度来说，
堵起来很舒服的，
他就会让人，
昏昏欲睡，
如果都是动，
然后你又会觉得，
强刺激，
没有松弛，
和喘气的机会，
所以这个小说，
就在这个，
节率上面，
也做到了，
几乎可以说，
是一个，
完美的，
动静结合的，
一个组合。
刚刚小娇讲的，
也让我有一些，
启发,
引用一段，
即跟在访谈里面，
说的话，
记者问他，
为什么选择，
短片小说，
他说,
可能是他的强度，
以及他不强调，
戏剧冲突，
短片小说开始时，
事情已经发生，
戏剧冲突，
已经结束，
所以,
比起,
整段婚姻，
破裂的过程，
你要写的是，
一个男人下班回家，
在路上买了汽油，
再买一包香烟，
他有很多年没抽烟了，
他坐下来抽了两只，
然后意识到自己，
不想回家，
于是回家对妻子说，
我不想再这样生活下去了，
这就是短片小说，
即跟又说，
我对张力和失落更感兴趣，
我们如何失去，
又如何在失去中失控，
他讲的这个张力，
也是他一直，
重复的一个关键词，
就是他上个月，
又跟歌手杜阿里巴，
做了一个播客的访谈，
在这个里面，
他也说，
他认为，
tension和drama,。
是不一样的，
tension就是张力，
drama就是这种，
戏剧型，
这种戏剧冲突，
他还用了一个比喻，
他说,
如果在一个派对，
tension看到了drama,。
那tension就会离开，
我觉得他好像在说，
他的小说，
更多的是在写，
这种张力，
而不是真正的冲突，
你们怎么理解，
这两者之间的差距？
对，我要那个调书袋了，
来吧!
其实O'Connor,。
弗兰克，
奥康娜，
这个也是艾尔兰的，
最有名的，
短片小说家之一，
他有一个名片，
叫The Lonely Voice,。
应该翻译成，
孤独的声音吧，
是他一个，
研讨课的，
讲义,
做成的一个文档，
提到一点说，
其实短片小说，
不是微缩的长片小说，
这个是他的一个，
核心观点，
他说，因为短片小说里，
有长片小说中，
更少见的，
对人类孤独的强烈意识，
就我觉得，
这个对人类孤独，
描述的这种，
强烈的意识，
其实就是tension，
更多的是，
一种内心的挣扎，
刚刚息息聊到的，
即跟他自己也说的，
整段婚姻破裂，
之后的男人，
一个人下班回家，
坐下来抽烟，
这样的瞬间，
其实就是tension，
是一个孤独的瞬间，
一个人要面对，
自己内心时候的瞬间，
他不是抓马，
因为他里面也没有，
强戏剧张力，
但是你绝对能看到，
这些人内心，
是有一些波濤汹涌的，
但是这个东西，
是tension,。
所以我觉得，
一些短片小说吧，
捕捉的是这种东西，
而不完全是，
一个故事性很强的故事，
而且当然短片小说，
也是Oconor的一个观点，
就是说，
他描述的是一些，
被淹没的人群，
就是更不重要的人吧，
就是因为长片小说，
你的主角，
一定,
得有一些主角光环，
还得吸引人，
你得让人看下去，
否则的话，
这么长，
你是看不下去的，
你得开金手指，
你得是金庸的，
这个男主持，
是,
哪怕就是讨厌的人，
他也得有一些，
个人魅力在身上，
否则没有办法看下去，
但是短片小说，
给了作者们，
这个自由，
可以选择更，
不受重视的群体，
Oconor的原话，
说的是
submerged population groups,。
就是被淹没的，
这种群体，
就像这个小女孩，
这个故事里面的，
每一个人，
其实都没有什么，
戏剧性，
也没有什么独特的魅力，
但是,
一个没有被父亲，
牵过手的多余的孩子，
他的内心的孤独，
他到了这个地方，
又紧张，
又害怕的这种感觉，
但是慢慢放松下来，
像老员说的，
这个可能是，
这个小说的问题，
其实也是，
这个小说的张力，
所以我觉得，
这个不知道是，
艾尔兰文学的传统，
还是二十世纪，
一些短片小说家，
他们都在实验的方向，
我觉得，
确实是我，
最喜欢的短片小说的方向，
就是比起那些，
有反转的，
故事性的短片小说，
我觉得，
这种短片小说，
确实是展现了，
这个问题，
最强大，
也最难，
掌控的那个部分，
但是,
我还有一个观点，
我觉得，
这个会成为，
一门失落的手艺，
当下来看，
短片小说，
以及即跟，
这种类型的短片小说，
确实是失位的，
我们聊它，
我觉得，
老元的品位，
真的是特别好，
我们选了这个，
然后聊这个，
给更多的读者推荐，
我觉得，
是有必要的，
就是,
让大家知道，
这个问题，
其实是，
最难，最难，
它既要有，
对故事的把握，
又要有，
对实性语言的把握，
它结合了，
长篇小说作家，
和诗人，
所有最难，
掌控的那部分，
在一起，
才能成为一个，
即跟这样的，
短片小说家，
就是从人类智慧，
文学洁经的角度，
来说,
这样的小说，
是能给我们一个，
很好的吃饭的，
其实,
一个好消息，
是它的，
这个收留，
跟它另外一个，
短片小说，
都是艾尔兰的教材，
太好了，
其实,
我们有鲁迅的，
那些小说，
做教材，
也是很好的，
只不过小的时候，
不懂它的好，
我怀疑，
艾尔兰的小朋友，
也许读得太多，
是,
确实,
那这个小说，
对你们自己的，
创作有什么启发吗？
我觉得，
这个小说，
对我最大的启发，
就是这个小说里面的，
一句话，
到创作，
人和人，
确实是有天壤之别的，
跟我想的一模一样，
我就想，
人和人有B，
对呀,
我觉得，
人和人，
确实是有天壤之别的，
但是,
我很开心，
我能欣赏它，
我觉得，
我也很开心，
老娘,
跟你想的一模一样，
你看完，
不会觉得手痒，
想写。
因为,
我已经过了那个阶段了，
就是,
我知道，
比如说，
有很多人看，
撒利努尼的小说，
就觉得，
I can't do it,。
但是呢，
这个东西，
就是,
you can't do it,。
对,
你就 do不了，
然后呢，
我,
因为我已经很早就知道，
我读不了这个事情，
所以我就会觉得说，
我,
可以欣赏它，
对,
然后从里面，
得到,
所以我觉得，
我们,
当然是说，
讨论这个创作，
就说,
我们从它的这个东西里，
能学到什么创作的东西，
其实创作，
都是一个数层面的东西，
对吧,
你就是，
模仿,
或者是，
你自己也记一记自己的日常，
但是最终的最终，
是你,
怎么感受这个世界的方式，
而且我觉得，
是怎么认识这个世界，
就像,
如果一个，
探险家，
决定攀爬，
捉木,
拉马风，
这个故事，
它是引人注目的，
你能想象到，
它里面有非常非常多的困难，
可是一个，
做办公室的白领，
它一年，
爬楼梯，
上上下下，
从楼底到办公室，
如果没有电梯的话，
它的那个距离，
可能也相当于，
攀爬了一次，
捉木，拉马风，
就是你怎么在这个，
文元,
攀爬,
它的捉木，拉马风的过程当中，
找到戏据性，
我认为，
其实是比一个，
探险家，
决定,
攀爬,
捉木，拉马风，
更难找到，
更难写的，
但是我觉得，
这种故事，
我不知道，
可能有个人审美，
我就觉得，
非常的吸引我，
就是你怎么去写一个，
普通人，
攀爬他人生的，
捉木，拉马风，
说的太好了，
这个结尾太好了，
那今天关于，
爱尔兰小说家，
克莱尔吉根，
以及他的这一本收留，
以及关于，
养育,
关于爱，
关于,
短片小说的魔法，
我们就，
浅浅的，
聊到这里，
你对这些话题，
有什么想法，
就欢迎在，
评论区，
跟我们分享，
我们下期再见，
拜拜,